the largest public school district here
in the country has abruptly stopped in
person learning that's new york city
forcing more than a quarter million
students to stay home
new york city mayor bill de blasio
announced the move yesterday to make all
new york city public school virtual
again
leaving many parents scrambling this
comes as three percent of coronavirus
tests in the city come back positive
now that number has not been that high
since the spring mayor bill de blasio
joins us now first on cbs this morning
mr mayor thank you for joining us your
ears must be burning today
the parents are mad with you the kids
are upset
your critics are calling questioning
your competency for the job
help us understand your thinking here
gail look
my kids went to new york city public
schools i really do feel what parents
are going through i told them last week
we had to get ready for this possibility
parents are scrambling because it's
really tough to be a parent especially
in the age of the coronavirus but the
number one job i have is to keep people
safe
i said from the beginning we would be
led by the data and the science
i have the largest school system in
america
a lot of people said we would never be
able to reopen it but we did back in
september
this is a question how are you
justifying that three percent number
when the the data doesn't seem to
support it and neither neither do the
public health experts
i think that's what has people upset
disagree with that gail that the data is
very clear
that we have to keep our kids safe our
educators safe staff
we've had increasing rate obviously as
you said in your opening here in new
york city and everywhere around the
country
we set a clear standard we said if it
goes above 3 percent we're going to shut
down for a period of time but then we're
going to reopen
with a new set of additional health and
safety standards that's the key thing
before we're going to open again i think
the question for for parents and
for everybody right now is why three
percent the world health organization
says five percent the governor says he
wouldn't take action
uh as long as the state below nine
percent other cities and states around
the country have higher thresholds
you've chosen three percent you're
sticking to it
how come because we were the epicenter
of this crisis everyone knows that
we needed to bring our schools back in
the fall and we needed to show
parents and staff that they'd be safe so
we set a very stringent standard
and a whole lot of other health and
safety standards the distancing the face
mask for everyone
kids and adults alike and we proved that
schools would be safe but we said
if that rate went up higher we were
going to stop we were going to pause and
reset
our schools are going to come back but
they're going to come back with
additional safety standards
you're leaving the bars and the
restaurants open where it's been proven
that those are
super spreader places as opposed to the
schools
yeah gail the governor made clear
yesterday
that new york state is going to very
soon
be applying what they call an orange
zone standard to new york city and that
will
be closing uh indoor dining and a number
of other things so those restrictions
are coming very soon it's quite clear
but mayor in the meantime a lot of
parents are joking i guess i'll send my
kid to the bar today because that's
still open or maybe they can work out at
the gym pump a little iron
uh you know i want to know more about
your equation
here because the cost of this shutdown
we know are going to be significant it's
going to be significant in terms of
learning for children
the economy because parents can't work
domestic turmoil new york city
apartments are very small
that's the cost you've acknowledged
those costs can you quantify the benefit
here
tony the benefit is keeping people alive
and keeping people keeping people safe
look
we have to be clear about this history
we were the epicenter of the crisis and
a lot of people
truly believed it would never be safe
for our schools we come back until
there's something
we know you have to keep faith with
people and show will keep them safe
you're right on the we did not know back
in april but we do know now and there's
been an
evolution in the approach europe has
bars and restaurants closed but schools
are open
other states and president trump we have
to remember was calling for this in the
summer a lot of democrats were opposed
to it
but states have come around and said you
know we are going to prioritize schools
because that is so important
and so that's why this equation is so
important it's a cost benefit
you can't put any number at all on on
what the benefit's going to be and yet
we know the cost
sixty thousand kids don't even have
ipads to to learn at home
we have been providing free ipads for
every child in new york city your
chancellor said yesterday that they
don't have ipads for sixty thousand kids
it's really simple really clear
every child new york city needs one can
get a free ipad and any child doesn't
have it now we're going to get to them
right away and we've distributed over
300 000 we'll do more
but the bottom line is this safety and
health come first
we can and we will reopen our schools
but with an even higher and more
stringent standard
that's the bottom line new york city
schools will come back it's going to
require a lot more testing
but we will bring them back mr mayor
what about the quality of learning
my wife's a teacher at a charter school
here in the city they
a lot of teachers are concerned about
the virus and going in but they're also
concerned about kids falling behind and
increasingly say that's happening
a lot what do you do about that yeah
listen i'm really concerned about that
going all the way back to march when we
had to close originally
i think the key thing i'm a believer in
in-person education that's why i truly
want to get the schools back with the
right standards
and obviously once the vaccine is here
we're going to distribute it very
quickly in new york city and get our
schools back in a much
deeper way but that's not until the
earliest i think we have lost something
here with our kids
and what we've got to do is continue to
improve remote education continue to
make sure every kid has a device
needs them and get them back in the
classroom as quickly as we can safely do
it
was there an update was there an uptick
in coveted cases in schools
here in the city is that clearly the
upwards
the the challenge is everywhere in the
city it went from just a few weeks ago
gail
very isolated pockets in new york city
we're having serious upticks to now
unfortunately it's all five boroughs
numbers i'm talking about and of course
it's been affecting schools too we've
had a number of schools that have had to
be shut individually for that reason
that's why we have to get ahead of this
for safety's sake but we can put more
stringent standards in including a lot
more testing i think this is going to be
the key
a lot more testing school by school to
get them back and running yeah mr mayor
i think another thing i'd like to point
out that is upsetting parents is that
the
private schools are open so that
exacerbates inequality even more
and i want to call your attention to an
editorial by nick kristoff
generally a progressive columnist for
new york times who said that president
trump was right over the summer to call
for schools to reopen
because the science actually has come
around and supported that position
you were opposed then it seemed
political what do you say to people who
look at you holding to this three
percent which is more conservative than
anyone else in the country and they say
he's sticking to a political decision
it's politics again i don't think it's
political in the least
again it's ironic you're right president
trump wanted schools
open i generally disagreed with him
across the board but in this case
i believe from the beginning we had to
reopen and lots of folks thought
it couldn't be done safely in new york
city we proved it could be but we're
dealing with a new circumstance the way
you opened the broadcast was so clear
we're dealing with a new circumstance a
surge that we have to be very very
concerned about we got to reset this
equation
so i say to my fellow parents i don't
expect this to go for long i expect us
to come up with a new standard that's
more stringent we're going to ask a lot
of parents we're going to ask them to
get their kids tested a lot
but then we can come back that's what i
was running what is your timeline to
reopen do you have one
this next few days with the stay in new
york we're going to come up with a new
standards and announce them before
thanksgiving
and then i hope to be back in the next
few weeks but again i'm going to ask
a lot of parents to make sure kids are
tested very consistently i think that's
going to be the key
gail yeah right and then in the meantime
overwhelmingly black and brown school
district and low-income kids are going
to be back in very small apartments
for the foreseeable future that's why we
want again back in school they're trying
to look the right way the safe way
all right mayor de blasio thank you very
much